Speaker 1: A We have a David Pakman Show
subreddit, which you can find at David
Pakman dot com slash Reddit. A nearly thirty four
thousand of our viewers and listeners have signed
up so far. Some interesting posts I spotted this
morning that I want to take a look at with you.
Speaker 2: First is about Putin, Trump and Russia.
Speaker 1: And it says Putin poised to invade
Ukraine. Trump probably gnashing at
the bit so he can point his demonic
Speaker 2: finger at Biden's
Speaker 1: failure to prevent Putin
would love this support from his wannabe fellow
tyrant. Yeah, there is going to be this amazing
double standard that takes
Speaker 2: place maybe not from I mean,
Trump will say something, but who cares, right?
Speaker 1: But from from people on the right
where all along during the Trump administration,
they said, Hey, guys, we want to be friends with
Russia. Why do you want to go to war? War is bad
now. We now pretend not to like war. Let's all
get along. Putin's nice. Putin's good. All this
different stuff. And then if Putin does invade
Ukraine, those very same people will say, Why
wasn't Biden tougher? Why is Biden better? Why
is Biden weak? It's going to be an amazing double
standard, and I would say I look forward to it,
but it's actually horrifying, quite frankly. But
yeah, we're going to be watching the reaction
from the right, including Trump,
about what ultimately happens. Their
next post, I spotted, which was interesting. Hey,
David, do you think it's likely cinema and mansion
are being blackmailed? Wouldn't put it past a
significant percentage of the Republican Party
who has proven themselves to be willing to do
anything to subvert Biden, to blackmail to members
of the Democrats in order to stop meaningful
legislation from passing. You know, that's
not typically the way things work in the Senate,
usually in the Senate. They don't use blackmail,
which is more of like the stick. They use the
carrot, which is here's the stuff we'll give you
if you do or don't go along with this or whatever
the case may be. And that's more frequently the
Speaker 2: way that the way
Speaker 1: that it works rather than. Here's
what we're going to go. Here's what we're going to
do to you. If you do the wrong thing, it's here's
what we'll give you if you do the right thing. And
of course, you can say these are legalized bribes.
Speaker 2: It's a form of bribe.
Speaker 1: So blackmail, I think less likely
goodies as Donald Trump like to say,
more more probable. Another user
Speaker 2: posted an article
Speaker 1: about a Let's Go
Brandon store that opened in the
Speaker 2: state of the
Speaker 1: Commonwealth, as Donald Trump
likes to say of Massachusetts. I don't know
Speaker 2: too much about right wing means.
Speaker 1: I know that let's go. Brandon is a big
one right now. This can't possibly last too much
longer, can it? Like, I already feel like, you
know, the way I gauge what the right is obsessed
with. Is what kind of gutter trash my live stream
live chat is filled with, and a few weeks ago,
it was filled with people just posting Let's go
Brandon over and over again in all caps. And of
course, we were banning every single one of them.
And we're seeing a lot less of it right now
in the comments in general. So it feels as
though let's go. Brandon is already kind of
dying down, but if it's not, it's such a lame
Speaker 2: meme that I can't
Speaker 1: imagine it would last
too much longer. And I think if you're just
now opening up the Let's Go Brandon store,
Speaker 2: it doesn't seem like a particularly
Speaker 1: auspicious timing. That's that's
Speaker 2: my instinct. But let me know if
Speaker 1: it's going to have staying power
as the case may be. Join the discussion on
the subreddit David Pakman dot com slash r d.